now it's time for the uplift at eight
where we share stories that will bring
you some joy to your day a Chicago
family is taking hand-me-down clothing
to another level Serena stoneberg lapari
recently got married she wore her
grandmother's wedding dress making her
the eighth woman in her family to wear
it her grandmother Dale stoneberg bought
the dress for about a hundred dollars at
Marshall Field's department store in
1950. over the next 72 years it was
passed down to Adele's two sisters her
daughter and three nieces they all wore
the dress on their wedding day and they
were there to watch Serena walk down the
aisle as well Serena told us she thinks
the Gown is a symbol of luck
there have been no separations or
divorces by any of the couples who have
been involved in the dress
um so we definitely think there's
something special or lucky to it
how about that I think lucky is a word I
love Nate that they can hand it down
make a little tweaks on the dress and it
still holds up still hold that makes a
quality dress I think so too and no
separations no divorces every woman in
that family is like I'll take it when
y'all done with it give me that dress
Nate okay all right give me the address
size 10 or 12 I could do both that's
right all right